hello everybody welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
all doing fine
today's class will be for everyone for
men and women because
we will work on rhythm rhythm
rhythm rhythm rhythm is the most
important quality that you can develop
in order to dance more musically
because when you dance to a piece of
music and you translate it into movement
you are basically using the rhythm to
create your movement
yeah so rhythm is really the most
important quality of music for dancers
is the most relevant so then of course
it follows that
it's very important that dancers are
familiar with the elements of rhythm
what is freedom made of so you have to
be familiar
and really understand the concepts of
beat of accent
the concepts of double time subdividing
a bit
of half time grouping beats half time
and pause
which often are equivalent the concepts
of syncopation
which is accentuating a part of the beat
that usually doesn't have any accent
or the concept of triplet which is
dividing a bit in a number of parts
different from the subdivisions from the
rest of the piece yeah
we will see this later so this will be
the class today
after the warm up i will show you a
series of exercises
and in each exercise we will use a very
simple sequence
because we don't want to worry about
complex steps today's point is the
rhythm
and in each sequence we will use one of
these elements
of rhythm so that you can see how it
looks like
and how you can use it in your dance and
then we will have
and then a couple of extra exercises in
which we will combine
two of these elements for example we
will combine
double time and syncopation
or double time and triplet which is very
interesting okay
the point today is to help you develop
your sense of freedom
and to be familiar with very important
elements
and how you can combine them and use
them in your dance
okay so i hope you will enjoy the class
let's go for the warm up
okay warm up so if this is the first
video
you watch from the channel i will
explain every movement
but if you have watched other videos
from this series
the warm up is always the same because
it
prepares your whole body for work okay
so i will explain every movement now we
start with feet together
and we spend a few seconds just relaxing
breathing deeply finding our center
and letting the weight of our body go
down and feeling our whole food
in contact with the floor just like that
and then after we are relaxed we start
with
circles for the shoulders like this yeah
so remember
make a big circle and don't
bend the elbows yeah keep the elbows
relaxed
and only use the shoulders okay and we
do it eight times
so let's start one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight okay now we do circles with
the arms
like this yeah so you start with the
arms relax down
then you go forward with both arms then
you go
up make sure that the arms are straight
yeah don't bend the elbows like this
arms straight and then from here we open
the arms to the sides
yeah make sure that the hands are a
little bit behind your back
so that you really stretch the chest
yeah
and then back to the start position
yeah like this okay
and we do it eight times okay so let's
go
one
two keep the arms straight yeah
three
four don't bend the elbows
five
six keep the shoulders down
seven
and eight okay good
now we stretch the side of our torso
so with arms down and feet together
we raise one arm like this yeah until
the arm is vertical
towards the ceiling and then with the
handle is down you slide this hand
down your leg until you can touch your
knee
like this yeah so you have to bend and
stretch the side of your torso
so you keep the stretch a few seconds
and then when the hand that is
up you pull yourself up again until
you're vertical
you drop the arm and then you repeat it
with the other arm
like this yeah okay so we do it four
times to each side
so let's start raise the arm one
go down the knee hold it
now up and drop the arm
one go down
hold it go up
draw the arm two make sure the arm is
straight
yeah go down hold the stretch
and up drop the arm two
go down try to touch the knee if you can
hold it and up
three go down
hold it up
drop the arm three
go down slowly touch the knee hold it
and up and four
on this side go down slowly
hold the stretch go up
and four go down
hold the stretch
and up okay good now we open
our legs more or less shoulder wide
yeah and then we bend the knees a little
bit
we keep the hips straight and we make a
circle with our
arms at the level of our chest like this
yeah
and then we rotate the torso left and
right
now make sure that you keep your head
and your hips
looking forward don't do this yeah
keep hips and head looking forward so
you only
turn the torso and also make sure that
you're you're moving the torso and the
arms together
in one piece yeah make sure that the
hands are always in front of your
chest in front of your chest because if
your hands move past the chest
that means that you're just moving the
arm but you're not working with the
center so you need to keep the hands
always in front of your chest okay and
we do it
uh eight times twice yeah so let's go
six and seven and
eight eight more one and
two three and
four and five and
six and seven and
eight okay if something may crack
behind that's a good sign don't worry
it's good
yeah so you should feel loose now in
your back
now we stretch the knees yeah in the
next exercise
we will keep our knees straight all the
time you can grab your hips
and the idea now is to stretch the lower
back so
from this position we go forward
keeping the legs straight yeah until
your butt is parallel with the floor
yeah more than inspiring the floor and
then from here
we keep going down until your head is
hanging
yeah and then we bounce three times one
two
three and then we go up yeah and we
repeat this sequence eight times
so let's go one go down
parallel to the floor bounce one
two three and then up slowly
yeah two go down
bounce pass bounce and up
three go down
bounce bars palms and up
four palm spots
bounce up
five go down bounce
bounce bounce up keep the knees straight
all the time
six bounce bounce
bounce up
seven go down bounce
palms up and the last one
down bounce bounce bounce relax the head
and go up okay now
from this position we keep the legs
straight
maybe we open the legs a little bit more
just a little bit more
and then we do circles with the hip
like this yeah so you start from the
back
like this then you go side you know
then forward and then to the other side
and then back yeah try to make this
circle with the hip
as big as you can okay so we do eight
circles in one direction
and then we change the direction and we
do eight more okay
so let's do it together we start back
and then
one two
three four
five six
seven eight
and now we change direction one
two three
four five
six seven
eight okay now we're in the center and
we do the last exercise
for this exercise we put our feet
together again yeah
make sure that the feet are touching
each other that they are completely
together and also
the knees yeah the knees should also be
together
and then first we bend the knees and we
bounce
three times on the knees one two three
then we go up
and then we go on the toes and we hold
it a few seconds
yeah and then we go down again and we
repeat it
eight times okay so let's go for the
first
make sure your feet are together and
let's go
bounce bounce bounce and then
on the toes hold it
and go down two bumps bounce
bounce go up on the toes hold it
block the joint of the
of the foot so that you can stay yeah
and then down three bounce bounce bounce
go up on the toes lock the foot joint
i'm down four bombs bounce bounce
go up on the toes hold it
and down five bounce bounce bounce
go up
and down six bounce bounce bounce
go up on the dogs hold it
and down seven balance balance bounce
go up on the toes hold it
and down and the last one balance
balance bounce
go up hold it
down okay so relax the legs
a little bit and we are ready with the
warm up we can go
for the first exercise okay first
exercise
for all the exercises we will use a very
simple sequence
because we want to focus on rhythm and
timing
and not worry about complicated steps so
we will do this sequence we start with
feet together in zero position
then you switch your weight to one leg
doesn't matter which one because we will
use both
and then you do one step forward you
change right in zero position
you do one step back and you change
weight in zero position yeah
very simple forward change back
change forward change back change
now in this combination there is one leg
that is the active leg
because it's the first leg that
initiates the movement in one direction
and then the other leg is the passive
leg because it follows
the active leg in the same direction so
this leg is active
because it's the first one going back
and this is passive
because it follows going back okay
so active passive active passing
why is this important because internal
music usually
beats are grouped in two yeah and you
have a strong beat
and a weak beat one two one
two the one is strong and the two is
weak
and you have two legs and this is ideal
to use an active leg for the strong beat
and a passive leg for the weak beat
so that your movements fit with the
accents
of the beats yeah strong weak strong
weak strong weak strong weak
yeah now this doesn't mean that
the weak leg moves too passive
or too dead yeah the weak leg should
also have accent
but the accent is not as strong as the
accent of the
leading leg of the active leg yeah
strong up strong weak
but weak with accent weak with accent
bum bum
yeah you see both legs are active but
one because it's dancing the strong beat
is a bit more active than the other
okay good so
we will work with the metronome yeah
like this
yeah my metronome is set at 58 bpm
it's said to play two beats per bar you
can hear it
one two one
two yeah and in this exercise we will
um use just the leads yeah
one two one
two forward change
back change like this okay
now because this is about rhythm um
don't go crazy with technique yeah but
it's important
to remember the basics yeah for example
when you do the exercise you should have
a straight posture of course
during the whole exercise the chest a
bit forward
you should do the whole exercise with
your knees a little bit bent yeah
the whole exercise the knees are a
little bent
don't lift the feet of course don't lift
the feet like this
you have to move your feet through the
floor
yeah in contact with the floor
and the last thing regarding technique
is that
try to hold the open position of the
step
as long as you can so when you do the
step forward
don't close the other leg too
early yeah keep it back as
long as you can and then close it
at the very end when the beat is coming
this will help
have a passive leg that still has
accent yeah so hold the open position
and hold the opponent position okay
that's it so um
we will count the exercise like this
you start in zero position and you
forward change back change
these are eight changes of weight yeah
one two three four five
six seven eight so every time we
complete
this block this will be one repetition
this will count as one repetition
and we will do eight okay eight sets
of eight changes away don't worry
because i will count with you
so that you don't get lost yeah so we
will start first
with the left leg as active leg
we will do eight repetitions and then we
will change side
and we will do it again using the right
leg
as the active leg yeah and i could show
you the exercise from behind
yeah so that you would follow the same
side
but i prefer to show it to you from the
side because
it's better to see the lateral movement
of the leg
and to see the step better okay in this
case
so i will
put the metronome here and remember that
this is about rhythm the most important
thing
of the exercise yeah the reason we do it
is that you try to step as
exactly as possible with the metronome
yeah
that when you put the foot on the floor
is exactly
when you hear the bit of the metronome
this is about improving
your timing okay so let's start with the
left leg
yeah get ready zero position
let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
okay usually if i was training
on my own for me for myself i would keep
going yeah
i will do it many more times but because
i want to keep the video
short i just show you eight times okay
but when you train for you
i recommend you to do it many more times
okay so now let's
change the side and the active leg is
now
the right one okay so let's do it eight
times
ah one
two
[Music]
three
or
hey
okay
easier but remember that
the point is to be precise with the
metronome
and what i recommend you is to think of
slowing down your movements
try to dance as slow as possible move as
slow as possible
but that you are still in the temple in
the right angle because
in my experience all of us we all have
the problem that we
step a little bit too heavily always we
step a little bit before
the beat there is a tendency to
anticipate
so what i think when i practice this
is that i want to dance actually a
little bit slower
from what i think i should dance and
usually
my timing improves i i managed to be
more precise
when i slow down okay and you will look
better if you slow down a little bit
because you will
you will feel more in the beat okay
so let's go to the second exercise okay
in the second
exercise we will keep the same sequence
that we did before
but we will use a double time yeah
a double time is nothing more than
a extra subdivision that we do between
beats
so it will sound like this if these are
one two one
two a double gun will sound like this
one
yeah and the reason why it's called
double time is that
this subdivision makes that you are
moving
at down on the temple yeah double the
speed
so that's why it's called double time
yeah this is faster
okay so the way that we will do it is
we start in zero position and then for
the first
four beats we will use only the beat
yeah so we will do
one two three four
and then we will use a double time twice
like this one uh two
ah one two yeah this is the block that
we do
i do it again for you one
two one two
one uh two ah one
two notice that i started back
and now i finish front so now i have to
do
everything in reverse backwards yeah
one two one
two one uh two ah
one two okay
so this is the exercise if you're a
woman
you can start with the back step if you
want yeah that's an option
when i go forward you go back when i go
back you will forward
okay that's up to you so
um let's keep this subdivision here
because we will use it and
again try to be precise to the metronome
yeah
usually just one more thing when we do a
double time
yeah and we do it with the music
usually the this step the exchange of
weight that we do between
bits yeah the double time itself usually
slowly yeah the timing is not good it's
not really
in the middle between bits it's
somewhere in between
yeah but it doesn't look too bad
because the music has many things
happening
and it hides the bad timing
but when you're working with a metronome
and this is the advantage of working
with a metronome
there is nothing else to distract you
there is no there is no melody
nothing is just beats as
very specific moments in time very
precise
so when you work with the metronome and
you are doing the exercise
and you do the double time it's very
very easy to hear
and to feel if your double time is
really precise
when the metronome sounds or if it's off
yeah
and of course the point is that
you put this on yeah one
two on the up you put it right
when you hear the beat the subdivision
of the beat on the bedroom
okay so it's all about timing
okay so let's start
do it eight times now i start with my
left leg
as activate let's do it together
one
two
three
four
bye
six
seven
eight
okay good now let's change sides
and we do it with the right leg as
active leg
okay one
two
three
or
bye
six
hey
okay
remember and i cannot insist enough in
this
if you do it wrong usually is because
you are anticipating you step
a little bit before the beat so really
try to think
slow slow move slowly place
each change of weight precisely
on the beat when you hear it on the
metronome yeah
delay it a bit yeah and then you will
actually be
much more on the beat okay let's go to
the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will use half
time or a pause
the reason it's called half time is
because
you are moving for a while at
half the tempo so half the speed yeah so
half time
yeah and this is usually what it means
to do
a pause in tango that there are one or
more beats that you don't dance
so we will use the same tempo same beads
yeah and the way we will use the beats
the structure of these exercises like
this you start in zero position
same sequence but now we do three
changes of weight
on the beat and then on the fourth beat
we do a pause like this
one two three
pause one two
three pose okay
now one thing about the pose in the pose
you don't want to freeze the movement
you don't want to do it one two
three one two
three and then continue now opposing
downward a beautiful posing tango
needs movement yeah so what you want to
do is to slow down your movement
yeah actually you you you do what you
would do normally
if you dance on the beat but you just
slow it down
so that you let a big pass without
changing weight
so what you do is beat beat
here you project the leg and then you
slow down your movement and you do a
slow transfer of weight
yeah slow transfer void from one foot to
the other
so that the pose doesn't look dead yeah
slow transfer
and then you hear the beat that you are
not using for a change of weight
beat and then you continue one
two three now this pose you do with the
feet together
yeah so here you can also do a slow
transfer of weight from one
foot to another and to accentuate what
is coming after the pose you can also
bend your knees slowly go down slowly
during the pause so that you have even
another
anticipation for the next movement and
then you continue
one two slow transfer of weight
one two slow transfer void
and bending the knees to prepare for the
next step
okay in this way your um
your poses will look very beautiful
and will will have tension because the
movement
in the post is slow movement the pose is
anticipating what's coming
so this creates tension because people
who are watching you dance
are looking forward to the resolution of
the pose
and to you doing the next movement okay
so that's
how you want to answer those okay so
let's do it with the metronome again
i'll put it here i will do it eight
times
using the left leg as the active leg
okay so get ready let's go
one
to
three
four
five
six
seven
okay
okay now change side
and i'm using the right leg as the
active leg okay
let's do it three times
one
[Applause]
two
green
or
bye
six
seven
hey
and that's it okay
be careful with the timing of the step
after the box because if you have
balance
problems that step probably will be too
early
because you have to save yourself so try
to
bend the knees go low try to to keep the
core tight
and have good balance so that the timing
of the step
after the pause is precise is on the
beat and not too early
okay great let's go to the next exercise
okay next exercise we will use
syncopations
yeah what is a syncopation a syncopation
is an
accent that happens in a place where
usually there is no
accent so for example if you have one
two one two usually the one
has the accent and the two doesn't or it
has a
weaker accent if you accentuate the two
instead of the one
then you have a single patient for
example in regular music
regular music is syncopated because it
has two beats
but they accent the two the second beat
one two one two one two
so this gives it a very just a very
regular feeling
yeah obviously the syncopation
can be anywhere you want yeah it can
also be
in between beats on the up for example
if you have
one a two one and two and you accentuate
an
ah like we will do now you have for
example
one two one up two
or one two r one
other one yeah if you put an accent
a step a strong step for example with
the leading leg
on the arm before the one or after the
two or before the two
then you have a syncopation you are
accentuating
a place a moment in the in the music
a bit that usually doesn't have any
accent
yeah so the rhythmic structure that we
will use now
will be like this we will start
with two steps on the beat
one two and one
up and the third step with the active
leg
will be on an up between these therefore
is a single patient we are accepting a
moment between these
so it's like this one
and two and one uh
and then with the following leg i am
also
going to use a syncopation yeah because
because i will step on the ah after the
two
two up and then i will finish
using the bead and one and two
and one and two yeah so it's like this
i do it very slowly one
and two and one
two up one and two
and one and two yeah with a metronome
like this one
two one
so we have beads and then we have these
two single patients there in between
okay i hope you got it anyway i'm gonna
do it now eight times
with each leg for you so you will be
able to
see exactly how it works
yeah so let's practice syncopation
eight times using the left leg as
leaning
let's go one
two
three
four
5.
six
seven
hey
okay if you have problems following what
i'm doing
just try to remember these rhythms
let's do it now eight times using the
right leg as a leading leg
okay let's do it together
one
two
three
four
five
six
hey
okay syncopation
try to really accentuate that ah yeah
one two three ah
yeah this is a surprise yeah if you use
it in your dance
and it fits the music obviously um
your rhythm your the rhythm in your
dance will be very very effective
okay so practice this okay let's go to
the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will continue
with single patients but we will try
something a little more sophisticated
because
in this sequence we will have now more
single patients
we will combine them with double times
and
also the syncopations will be in more um
interesting and fine places than before
yeah
in the previous exercise we divided the
beat
in half yeah so we have one up
two up one ah two up so just
one subdivision in the beat and it
sounded like this
yeah one two one
two that means that if you wanted to
dance
a syncopation you had only one place
where you could put it
which is the up so in this exercise
we will divide the beat not in two parts
but in four parts
yeah so you will have the
main beat the one and then three ups
it sounds like it's one ah a two
a one a a two yeah that's if i count
this if i count sub divisions you have
four subdivisions in the beat and it
sounds like this
one two three four one two three four
one two three four yeah
in the metronome it would sound like
this
one two uh one
yeah so why do we do this because now
with more subdivisions you have more
resolution inside the beat
yeah and more choices uh
to where to put the syncopation uh
it doesn't have to be anymore in the
middle of it it can be
in any of the four subdivisions or the
three if you
exclude the first bit so
that allows you to create more
interesting and sophisticated rhythmic
patterns
with single patients because now the
syncopation can be in any of these two
divisions
okay so um the sequence that we will do
works like this remember that
in our sequence we have eight bits yeah
the sequence takes
eight bits to complete and now each beat
is divided in four
uh parts yeah four subdivisions so
on the first beat we start in zero
position
this is where the difficulty starts
because the first step
we are not going to do this step on the
one which would be
the natural thing to do we will do it on
the two
or in other words on the uh after the
one immediately after the one so if we
have four subdivisions
it sounds like this one two three four
one two three four
one two three four one two three four
you see
this is our first single patient because
we are
with our step we are accentuating
a part of the beat that usually wouldn't
have any accent
at all yeah the two wouldn't have any
accident at all
one two three four so we are
accelerating that part
one two three four okay that's the first
key
on the second beat we will have
two steps we will step on the one
which is the natural place and on the
four
which is the last subdivision so it will
sound like this
one two three four yeah one two three
four the first one is not as simple
patient because we're accentuating the
natural beat
but the four is a syncopation because
it's a subdivision that usually
wouldn't have any accent yeah so
so it will be like this one two three
four
yeah so so far we have
one two three four one two three four
yeah
that's very syncopated
okay on the third bit
we will accentuate with our step the
third subdivision of the beat
so it will sound like this one two three
four
one two three four one two three okay
and the three usually is where
you put a double time if you want to
dance at double time
usually and you have four subdivisions
in the beat
usually you are accentuating the three
one two three four
one two three four that's another time
one yeah so you could say well it's not
really a syncopation
it's a double time but i
consider it as incompatible why because
for it to be a double time you would
have to also do a step on the one
one two three four one yeah then it
would be a lot of time but because
we are not doing any step on the one we
are only using the three
by itself then it is a syncopation
yeah because it doesn't have the one
before
with a step one two three four yeah
so so far we have one two three four one
two three
four one two three four yeah one two
three four one two
three four one two three four okay
now the fourth bit um in this one we
will have two steps
and the steps will be on the second and
the third subdivision of the beat
so it will sound like this one two three
four
one two three four so the two
is a clearly a single patient because
it's the r that comes right after the
one
one two the three is a level time
because it's usually the middle of the
beat so that's where you put a lot of
time
but because you don't have the one you
could say that it's also syncopation so
depending how you look at it you have a
syncopation and a double time
one right after another or you just have
two single patients one
right after another depending how you
feel about it yeah
so so far the first four beats
are like this one two three four
one two three four one two three four
one two three
four yeah again one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two
three four okay so these are the first
four bits
and then we have four bits more but in
these four
uh bits on the second part of the
sequence
we will use just the one yeah like the
first
exercise yeah we will do one two three
four one two three four one two three
four
one two three four that's the good news
so very simple so we have some time to
rest
between single patients yeah so the
whole exercise
the whole sequence doing slowly
yeah looks like this
one two three four one two three four
one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two
three four
one two three four one two three four
one two three four one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two
three four one two three yeah with a
metronome i mean once
counting for you so that the rhythm
is clear
yeah one two three four one two three
four one two three four so what we have
is like this
one two three four one two three four
one two three four one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two
four one two three four one two three
four
three four one two three four one three
okay
you see it's two halves the first half
is four single patients the second is
just on the beat
okay so let's do it let's
do it together i'll put the metronome
here
and i will start doing it eight times
yeah i will count
each repetition of the sequence
eight times for you and i will start
with the
left leg as the leading leg okay
so zero position get ready posture bend
the knees
and let's go
[Music]
one
two
three
four
five
six
hey
okay remember that it
sounds like you have to do a lot of
stuff fast
but think about the movement slow
down slowly yeah one syncopation at a
time doing it slowly
okay right leg is leaving right now
let's do it three times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
yeah okay
great if you want you can do this
exercise
in pairs if you have somebody to to work
with
practice embrace or even tango embrace
yeah you can do the exercise together
because it's great to check
if you have a good sense of timing with
your partner
and if both members of the couple
understand the timing in the same way
especially
that you are able to step exactly at the
same time
yeah you can also record yourselves on
video
and then do the exercise and then check
the video watch
if your legs are stepping exactly
on on on the beat yeah with the
metronome
and together with each other yeah that
would be ideal
okay let's go to the next exercise okay
in this exercise we get into triplets
and what are triplets
triplets are temporary supervisions of a
beat
in three parts yeah in the previous
exercises we have divided our beads
always in an even number of parts for
example
in two parts one ah two uh one
uh two or in four parts one
ah a two ah a one a two yeah
but you can also divide it in an odd
number of parts for example
three that's why it's called three plate
yeah one
two ah one two if you cancel divisions
it's like one two three one two three
yeah in the metronome it's very easy to
set
triplets up they sound like this yeah
each bit is divided in three parts now
when you hear this
yeah you might say
yeah but this sounds like balance right
balance rhythm
well technically it's not the same
balance better and triplets is not the
same because
in balanced rhythm what you have is
three beats three beats that
are grouped together one two three one
two three
and this grouping of bits in three
um is the same is constant throughout
the piece
from the beginning of the last till the
end of the match you always have three
bits
one two three one two three grouped
together but when you have a triplet a
triplet is different because
a triplet is a temporary momentary
subdivision
of a single bit in three parts in a
piece that
otherwise has a different rhythmic
structure
it has a two rhythmic structure or a
four
yeah so in advance you will always have
one two three one two three one two
three that's because it's a balancing
but in a trap that has a triplet you
have
one uh two ah one ah two
ah one two ah one up
up two you see there was only one
beat that was divided in three parts not
the whole thing
that's when you talk of a triplet and
triplets are
great to create tension rhythmically or
to highlight
a part of the of the piece of the tango
in this case
that is a climax or a high point in the
music
yeah so if you can follow the clip that
with your steps
then that's great that's absolutely
great so
the sequence that we will do now is very
simple
we will use the triplet rhythmic
structure of the
metronome and the eight bits that we
have
will be like this so we will do two
steps
following the beat just following the
beat yeah so
one two and then we will do
four steps doing a triplet
and the next beat so one
two okay and then we will repeat this
structure again
going backwards first two steps on the
beat
one ah two
and then four steps following a triplet
and the next
beat
and then repeat yeah one
two one
one two one
and two so with the metronome
yeah we have this
step step step step
step step step step step step
you see quite simple okay just to get
used
to the feeling of attribute okay
so let's do it um eight times
with both legs
one
two
three
four
bye
seven
hey
okay try to be clean with the timing
precise it will help you to have your
knees bent
during the exercise okay so let's do it
eight times more
now the right leg is in the leading leg
one
two
three
four
five
six
hey
okay great
again i recommend you if you have
somebody try it
in a couple yeah see if you can
match exactly each other's rhythm
timing and tempo with the metronome okay
so let's go to the last exercise okay in
this last exercise we will stay with
triplets
but we want to try something a little
bit more sophisticated because we want
to combine
in the same sequence steps based
on dividing a bit into like in a double
time
with steps based on a bit
divided in three like a triplet so we
want to combine double time and triplet
in the same sequence
so how does this work imagine that i
play you
the triplet again on the metronome yeah
it's like this
one yeah so you have three subdivisions
one two
three one two three yeah one two three
one two three now if you play a b
divided in two
remember it sounds like this
[Music]
so if you have the bit divided into on
the triplet
what you have is the one the two
and then in between the two and the
three of the triplet you have a point
in the middle which is the subdivision
of the beating two
yeah so it would sound like this if you
play them together it will sound like
meanwhile this is doing one
yeah i hope this is clear yeah you are
playing triplets
and a bit subdivided in two at the same
time
okay so unfortunately
the metronome cannot play this cannot
play
both at the same time either it plays a
triplet
or it plays a bit super divided into so
what i will do
is to set the metronome to play the
triplet yeah
and then the division in two we have to
put it there ourselves
the metronome won't play it for us okay
so that's where you have to be careful
with your timing so the sequence that we
will do
works like this you start in zero
position
and then the first step is on the one
yeah
one so very simple now the first thing
we do is a double time
yeah a double time like this one
ah two okay double time this is a bit
divided into
now we wait in this open position
between
steps and then we do a triplet and the
next speed
yeah one ah two
okay now we're in this position again
now we repeat
the same sequence so we do the double
time
one and two and then we do the triplet
one and ah two okay the triplet on the
next bit
now hopefully we finish in zero position
forward
so that we can repeat the whole thing
now go starting backwards
so first comes the double time one
ah two and then comes the triplet
one two and then again
double time and the next bit one ah
two and the triplet and the next bit one
one and two okay
if i play with the metronome remember
the metronome is playing triplets only
so the double time we have to put it
ourselves okay
double time
okay that's the sequence i'm gonna do it
eight times
okay so let's do it let's do it together
i'll put the method
here
and i will count with you eight
repetitions
and i start with the left leg forward as
the leading leg
okay so zero position
let's go
one
two
hey
four
five
six
seven
hey
okay now change sides
and we use the right leg as a leading
layer
remember to flex your knees so that it's
easier
to do fast steps okay so let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
okay good
be careful with the double time yeah
because it's not played by the metronome
and if you're not careful
you might move that double time
the step in the middle towards one of
the triplets
yeah instead of doing
you might be doing
yeah and that's the wrong timing because
you are
using one of the triplets when you want
to use the middle
um of the beat yeah so be careful with
that
okay so those were all the exercises
i hope you enjoyed this and
uh try this if you have difficulties
doing the steps um doing the sequences
with your with your feet yeah
dancing them um i recommend
start the exercise just by clapping yeah
with a metronome or with some reference
that you have yeah
start by clapping because the main thing
is to develop your sense of rhythm
yeah and for that first you have to
understand the rhythm you have to
understand
the structure you are playing so with
clapping is much
easier you don't need any technique and
it helps you to quickly
understand this rhythmic structure
you're trying to to do
and then when the rhythm is really clear
and you're satisfied with your clapping
that your clapping is precise
then you can try exactly the same with
your feet
yeah the goal is to do that rhythm
precisely with your feet okay
so thank you very much for watching i
hope you have fun
and i'll see you in the next video
bye-bye